one of the most important concepts in
modern economics is the idea of demand a
functioning economy
has to have a healthy level of demand in
it for lack of demand invariably leads
to the most awful spectra of all
recession
therefore government's carefully track
how much demand there is and are careful
to apply a stimulus whenever it looks as
if there isn't any this involves
maneuvers like lowering interest rates
cutting taxes and loosening credit in
all manner of ways for example in a
typical piece of demand stimulus in
December 2008 fearing a recession the
Australian Government gave a present of
$1,000 to every family in the country
encouraging them to go out and spend so
as to avoid economic disaster currently
the focus of economics is entirely on
the quantity of demand on trying to get
people to spend more money on well
pretty much anything it's not what they
spend money on that interests economists
it's that they spend it on something
very little attention has so far ever
been devoted to the issue of the quality
of demand it's considered entirely
irrelevant by economists and governments
what people are spending on they might
be buying donuts or taking french
conversation classes seeing us like a
therapist or purchasing a sports car in
terms of GDP unemployment and the stock
market it doesn't matter in the least
what they're buying so long as the total
spend is high enough
the only caveat is that it is a headache
for the state if too much expenditure
goes to overseas businesses yet clearly
in other ways it does matter what we
spend our money on because the combined
purchasing choices of millions of people
shapes the kind of society we live in
and the kinds of lives most of us end up
leading if everyone wants game shows on
TV and doughnuts with marzipan coating
for supper a lot of us will end up
working in those industries if on the
other hand there is little demand for
poetry or couples therapy or ritualized
tea drinking by moonlight in straw and
wooden huts it was big in 16th century
Japan few people can end up working in
these areas and if they do they won't
earn much this is where a major
statement a value judgment comes in
there is better and worse demand demand
for handguns is we can say with
assurance less good than demand for
education demand for healthy food is
better than demand for junk food our
societies should feel less nervous about
treading into the area of values after
all in our own lives we know there are
better and worse things to spend money
on and that's not different at a macro
scale good demand is defined as a
consumer choice that's in line with
fruitful needs it properly pays off it
contributes to better lives in the long
term there would be a single set of
purchases right for everyone but that's
not the point
the issue is merely to get the debate
started and to draw attention to the
fact that there are better and worse
purchasing decisions and that a society
needs to discuss what these might be
instead of just focusing on demand per
se raising the quality of demand doesn't
imply a track kuhnian government
imposing some supposedly high-minded
agenda on a reluctant public demand in a
market oriented democratic society is
and can only ever be voluntary raising
demand
I'll be a matter of forcing anyone to do
anything but what we need is the more
important or humane task of encouraging
ourselves to be wiser in our purchasing
decisions a phenomenon we don't pay
enough attention to is the education of
the consumer poor choices are not innate
unmovable characteristics they're simply
what happens when you don't have the
chance to learn with the right engaging
guides we can overhaul our ideas of what
we want in many areas we've done it to a
great extent already around food but to
travel furniture housing design
education psychotherapy and
relationships all stand in need of a
little help if good demand were more
normal it would transform society
there'd be fewer jobs that felt
demeaning or degrading because more
demand would be directed towards more
meaningful needs profit wouldn't look
sinister or suspect it would be a sign
that a company was doing the right thing
and doing it rather brilliantly we've
been too ready to accept that what
people want is some kind of a movable
force in fact it's entirely subject to
change it's simply a pity that the only
people who actively seek to change what
people want are corporations with very
large advertising budgets and often
rather doubtful things to sell us it's
time for philosophers and others to
engage in a complex ethical task of
influencing public wants we need to take
up the task of creating better demand
you
you